hallo PlayStation Plus subscribers
August 6 free video games have been
revealed and it's fair to say it's a
pretty weak month this time around we
have physics puzzles space combat action
adventure rhythm games more rhythm games
and an arcade blaster this month let's
start with the ps4 kicking off this
month collection is tricky towers which
brings the addictive block building of
Tetris and introduces physics and
gravity to the situation this game
offers local multiplayer and could be
fun if your friends come round the
average rating for this it's about 7 out
of 10 next up is rebel galaxy which is a
space shooter in which you micro manage
your space vessel and roam the galaxy
making friends and more often than not
enemies if you're the fan of the space
battles found in many of the Star Trek
games this is one for you but I must
admit feeling slightly let down by this
game over to the ps3 for this month's
shining star Yakuza 5 if you haven't
played the Yakuza series I recommend it
the parallels with GT are apparent when
playing this open-world outing but the
fighting aspects sets it apart from its
western counterpart and more like
Sleeping Dogs this is easily the game of
the month so dust off your ps3 and give
it a go the second option on ps3 is
retrograde don't be fooled by the look
of this game it is nothing like our type
or resogun but instead is a music and
rhythm game the backgrounds can be
distracting the music can be terrible
Rissa freebie so it's acceptable over to
the PlayStation Vita which gives us the
PSP classic Patapon 3 yet another rhythm
game this one steers away from space and
his Dead brings a cartoony childlike
feel to the rhythm genre this game
offers more depth in retro grid by
incorporating RPG elements but
ultimately feels the same the last game
of the month is ultra Tron this is a
dual stick shooter where your left stick
moves your robot and your right stick
shoots it feels a lot like Robotron if
you ever played back if you want to be
challenged this is the game for you it
becomes extremely tough in no time ok so
that's all our games for the month I'm
rather let down by this month games and
I'm already looking forward to
September's offerings what do you think
sound off below if this video has helped
at all please consider subscribing
I've been Adam from place
in granade see you again soon